mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
viele sehnen sich nach der ruhe in grün
im zuge von corona gewinnt das dörfliche
gegenüber der dicht bebauten starts an
attraktivität
wie lebt die schweiz dieser landlust zu
besuch bei einem der sie geradezu
zelebriert
[Musik]
und sorgen
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz heute
machen wir station im berner oberland
und zwar im 500 seelen dorf hofstetten
bei brienz und dieses dorf das meint der
schweizer sänger marc trauffer wenn er
singt daraufhin geboren und sorge
seine musik das sage ich ihnen gleich zu
beginn ist nicht ganz nach meinem
geschmack aber das phänomen drauf hat
das interessiert mich sehr
da singt eine ziemlich simple sachen
über das landleben und hat einen
riesigen erfolg damit
es muss also eine unstillbare sehnsucht
geben nach dem land und diese sehnsucht
die ist nach corona noch größer geworden
also auf zum mister land leben
[Musik]
ja und er ist schon mit dem posten der
hohen kante
das klischee passt doch gut wie gar
keine also in sie singen darüber dass
dort vor jetzt da sind und sich einmal
besuchen
ist ihnen das so wichtig ihre wurzeln
verschiedene zimmer wieder zurückzog
die gehalte der herr die fernseher in
bayern kommt in basel kann sind aber
immer wieder druck
was ich dann bedeutet für sie vom land
aber ich habe aber das gefühl vor der
heime sie und volle 35 die straßen und
häusern sowie guides und du willst du
mit mir gehen fand einfach dass das ist
schon aus dass man das auch um sich noch
nie so gemacht das gefällt mir ja der
erfolg gibt am markt darauf recht mit
seiner musik an sich polarisiert
in marc trauffer universum dem schweizer
alpen land
in schwarz-weiß fast symbolhaft auf ihn
zugeschnitten denn während die einen bei
seinen liedern jurte sehe andere schwarz
[Musik]
das sei zu viel oder zu wenig inhalt
sagen kritiker
[Musik]
künstlerischen anspruch und die wird mit
lyrischen texten überhaupt nicht
glücklich machen
der 41-jährige zelebriere ein zu helles
ludwig idyllisches heimat bild
[Musik]
es gibt so viele ist die stadt beruft
langkammer am wochenende andere und
italien momente das ist anlass geil
finden für die terrasse von dessen und
sagt hey guck mal wie schön dass das ist
wenn es aber die trophäen der videoclip
machte ich es irgendwie verdächtig mit
alten themen wie er es nennt scheffel
trauffer millionen und dabei räumt er
freimütig ein kein begnadeter musiker zu
sein
kuranyi
[Musik]
musik sei zwar berufung nicht aber sein
beruf
ja
musik ist es auch nicht außer kontrolle
geratenes hobby also dass das kann man
nicht anders bezeichnen
sein beruf chef des holzspielwaren
familienunternehmen in dritter
generation
[Musik]
der tausendsassa verkauft spielzeug
musik gadgets sich selbst unter war
immer auch ein stück rain ihn wegen
seines patriotismus und das projekt
führt zur burg mit dem svp nölle
politisch rechts zu verorten sei aber zu
simpel meint der wechselwähler
[Musik]
ja
ich glaube die toleranz waffengesetz zum
beispiel da bin ich ganz ganz große
liebe dieses land das mittelland dialog
er einen shitstorm löste trauffer 2017
mit diesem song aus dieses frauenbild
für viele ein affront
[Musik]
trauffer polarisiert das schlägt kreise
sie sind verrückt ich meine hallo ja ein
bisschen etwas von macao das ist und
dass man sagen dass man sich über eine
statue heidi ebene gefragt das hat mit
einer stunde also wirklich dass das so
hochkochen ist wurde
ich glaube aber jederzeit zum beispiel
spielt hätte ich sehr selbstbewusst und
sehr ehrenvoll und dass man sich also
dass das nach dem ausgleich durch worte
hätten es aber nicht
richter bringt das muss ich also ich bin
nicht die einzige frau wo sie mit einem
konfrontiert hat in der letzten zeit und
wohin der sexismus uns geleitet hat was
hat das mit ihnen gemacht hat das
überhaupt bis man ihn ich mache ja also
erlebt wie vorsichtig das ist ja schon
klar aber das geht nicht nur mir so das
geht im moment ein politiker so es geht
einer großen dynamik es liegt dass man
im regal hat oder man schreibt ja ich
glaube mich sehr wohl aber im moment ist
das denn so sagt sie das nicht wirklich
gut findet doch ich finde es sehr gut
dass man über der aktuell sehr über
diversität idee aber einig dass man die
die wer ist das eigentlich selber nicht
so passen wohl nicht ganz voll
entspricht das mit ihrer akzeptiert also
wie man verträgt aber die sofort
behandelt und jj mal als rückständig
petit letzte hätte das schon immer mit
offenheit irland sehnsucht oder ihre
heimatverbundenheit wird sowie dass man
darauf ihrem ober- und unterarm sogar
symbol von der schweiz ein sehr warmer
seilbahn lieber skript mit der sus alles
sv
abgesagt ist schon mal sehr sie sich
sponsoren verschwitzt uhr ist die idee
für das theater durch effektiven kosten
entstanden in costa rica bis 11.30 und
der isra liegen wird von costa rica
bruder wieder oder sogar land genau das
wird passieren wenn özil an das symbol
und das ist für mich das war oft
unverständlich ist neuseelands tattoos
befinde mir dass ihr tollem etc wenn
sich und das mit der musik jahrzehnt
nach dem land ist groß nicht nur bei den
fans von kauf der immobilien portal
zeigt sich elemente der schweiz suche
nach dem glück auf dem landsitz von
dieser landlust profitiert auch patrick
fritsch der chefredakteur des magazins
landliebe empfängt im sogenannten land
lieber haus natürlich während corona
haben noch mehr menschen sein heft
gekauft natürlich sehe vor der
landwirtschaft mit aber auch viel
service sache salatpflanze haben wir zum
beispiel mit zitrone geschichte
zitronenbäumen jahr pflanzen sehr große
teil woche rolle spielt wie hält pro
woche immer schon recht früh rakowitz
megatrend ist das geschäft mit der
landidylle prompt
die landliebe ist im zehnten jahr und
mit 669.000 leserinnen und lesern das
zweitgrößte bezahl magazin der schweiz
hier auf der forch entsteht das heft und
es werden zahlreiche kurse angeboten
landliebe garten und klanglich ist
konzept das eine virtuelle markus
sondern erlaubt auch die leserinnen und
leser des chors machen im land reviews
zum beispiel kompostieren kompost
hofbauer mit denen die stufe von
konfitüren kreieren über kräuter
gärtnern bis zur gemüse selbst ziehen
ein lebensgefühl wird hier vermarktet
drei viertel der landliebe fans sind
weiblich leben meist in der
agglomeration und träumen von da aus vom
schönen land leben
die landlust beschäftigt auch boris
privileg wir treffen den direktor des
instituts für die kulturen der alpen im
kapuzinerkloster althoff er erforscht
die zusammenhänge zwischen urbanem leben
und unserem drang hin zum land
die idee der ländlichen idylle
existierte schon bei den alten römern
ist eben das land lahm oder beschrieben
wird das sind meistens hier ein
sogenannter so wie immer sagt bonack mit
schwarzem oder ihres schönen beschwören
das sind im fiktiven ort das wird wohl
nicht die ursprüngliche bevölkerung her
das land wird paradiesisch verklärt in
zeiten der aufklärung idealisiert der
genfer denker jean jacques rousseau
denon naturell den von der gesellschaft
noch unverdorbenen menschen doch dieser
zivilisiert sich mehr und mehr
zugleich sehnt er sich nach dem
einfachen leben auf dem land schwierig
konstruktion das sage wie hätte man sich
wie sie sich untereinander sie den
sozialvertrag sind verhalten
und zweitens fällt rechnet das mit
zurück zur natur garten sind trotz sind
ein ziemlich aktions prozesstag
rückgängig mache zivilisations stress
auch auf dem feld für uri den knecht
miese arbeitsbedingungen und
komplizierte liebschaften
das land wird hier als ort erzählt wo
alles möglich ist alles gut wird
die hoffnung auf die heile welt hält
sich wacker der moderne hauptdarsteller
der landlust nik hartmann
publikumswirksam suchte er 13 jahre lang
in der idylle nach dem ursprünglichen
dem echten traditionen und trachten
sorgen für gute quoten und die
helvetische lust am ländlichen ist ein
wichtiger politischer faktor in der
schweiz das land so soziologin joel
zimmerli habe nicht nur dank der starken
bauernlobby viel einfluss sind bereit zu
investieren in die infrastruktur auf dem
land das ich glaube ich habe ein vorteil
für die schweiz nicht nur wohlstand dass
wir uns auch entflohen leichte schulz
immer lieber red gemeinden in raum
planungs und zukunftsfragen
sie spürt täglich wie unterschiedlich
städtische perspektiven und ländliche
realitäten sind es statistik 16 prozent
für die schweizer bevölkerung gewohnheit
wirklich auf dem land und die hand vom
land ihren alltag und die mütter
schaffen und sie mit dem lager wo sie
haben
und die hat nämlich das ganze anders
bild vom land dass sich der ort wo sie
sind uns stinkt's will es jetzt gilt es
hat immer noch landwirtschaften sie
schicken mir lud und städte mit ihrer
sehnsucht und ihre idee auf land und das
erste was ich mache diese geschichte
dass es stinkt oder nötig und das
schafft eine beliebig flächen die
mehrheit liegt also das landleben leid
lebt in der ag und liest am liebsten
ländliche geschichten des geräts sowie
zeige die positive sieht damit zeigen
natürlich auch in der geschichtlichen
dauerproblem forum war die idee
entstanden sind also die zeigen wie es
ist
aber sagen wir vorbilder herr ich die
positiv sieht bildete der wunsch nach
dem häuschen auf dem land wird weiter
bestehen
das schöne an dieser sehnsucht dass sie
nicht gelebt ist sehnsucht bleibt damit
kann das land land sei ein raum für die
imaginationen von uns allen
[Musik]
dass ihm seine werkstatt vom markt
darauf für und sie sind so der patron
von höchst aus bereits in dritter
generation valley weg transportieren sie
daraus leiter von einem kaum spürbarer
betriebsnummer schweizer holz
verarbeiten wir machen alles marktplatz
schweiz und das im regen mit der
holzkugel ich mich der bruder helfen zu
äußern
die ermittler sind irgendwie woher und
mädels was gibt es 45 uhr hoch und so
weiter und so mit deiner spiels wird
jetzt mal behaupten erfreut sie auch die
uhr bauen ältere klingt sowieso sei dank
es schon so dass soße es ist wieder
möglich wenn man sich eben lassen hat
und mich und somit die telekom es kam es
nach spieler und es ist natürlich so
dass wir gleich zum glück weniger
plastik im kinderzimmer mit und
schließlich liebe nach geraten
die abstimmung galt auf den
stadt-land-graben durchzieht also
wertvorstellungen aufeinander wo sehen
sie sich der politisch mit einem
spannungsfeld ja aber gerade für das
bedarf staub lang aber wo man probiert
hat schwarze sicher dass extreme links
oder extremer rechts somit alles immer
wie extreme und yamanashi es vor dass
irgendwann hier amerikanische traut es
geht und die normale banken die mittel
wegbricht
die gemeinde parteilos und ich habe
immer dazu auch an agieren und zeugen
habe abstimmen
typische wechsel war der betrieb nur
güter als privatperson im sachpolitik
hierbei nicht um eine thema wasser
bekommt und dominiert nicht so
irgendwelche partei diktat unter
umständen sich als wirtschaft die wäre
aus 14 uhr auf der bühne stand zusammen
mit dem kölner der sommer rettet sie
zwei muss sich auf die konzerte im
zürcher letzigrund mit einem die es
natürlich mittlerweile kronen das sind
konsequenz was wir als musiker mit drei
gesetzt ist ihre bilanz aus unseren
die bilanz sehe schon verrät und das ist
gerade mit natürlicher süße holstein
sieht das spiel zum fachgeschäft oder
sie geht es so wie nie geschafft in den
bergregionen diese alle zurück sie und
bis sie wieder soviel geld sicher mosley
und ja da müssen wir selbst tun sie
tröstet sie sich eine person ihr habt ja
sehr viele mütter probe für die
zulässige und chance und keine termine
er glaubt so wenig termine will ich
versuchen das dahin noch einmal
gründlich herunterfahren da wünschen wir
den soli frauenherzen gewöhnt
ja die korona krise drei monate sind
inzwischen vergangen seit der bund das
tor sofort hilfspaket geschnürt hat im
kulturbereich werden inzwischen stimmen
laut die kritisieren dass finanzielle
hilfe nur mit großem bürokratischen
hürden zu bekommen sei was läuft hier
falsch
wir haben nachgefragt nach wochen zu
hause ist veronika spielen burg wieder
in ihrem atelier
sie hat corona gelder des bundes
beantragt bislang aber noch keinen
rappen erhalten
das problem viele künstler sind
freischaffende wie die autorin monica
cantieni für freischaffende aber sind
keine corona gelder vorgesehen
sie müssen sich privat helfen wenn es
nicht mehr geht bleibt nur noch der
antrag auf nothilfe
sie steht allen kulturschaffenden offen
die sich nicht mehr über wasser halten
können
allein im mai gab es 800 nothilfe
gesuche die massnahmen des bundes seien
wirklichkeitsfremd sagt cathy eni zu
bürokratisch und zu aufwendig philipp
bischof direktor der pro helvetia kennt
die vorwürfe
es kommt hier oben berechnet vorsprung
des kaffees verfahren und faires
verfahren braucht
datenbasis und andere 6 uhr 200 und 6
207 das ist effektive regierungsführung
für alle betroffenen
übrigens für uns bei unserer
fördermaßnahme das qs anzahl der masse
hoch ist eine verstärkung kommt ist ihm
wahnsinnig leid vor allem ihn warte
doch warten will sie nicht darum hat
sich cantieni mit anderen künstlern an
den bundesrat gewandt
mir scheint es fehlt unkompliziertes
vornehmlich ein fixbetrag wo über
mindestens sechs manager zahlt wird auch
christoph stürmer vom verband
musikschaffende schweiz kritisierte die
hilfsmaßnahmen des bundes als nicht
ausreichend
[Musik]
einfach einfach wieder auf touren wieder
schaffe die schweizer musikszene fühlt
sich allein gelassen
die planungsunsicherheit ist groß
konzerte wurden in den herbst oder gar
ins nächste jahr verschoben
zudem wurde erst über ein fünftel der
gesuche für ausfall sind schädigungen
entschieden und viele befürchten dass
die 280 millionen des bundes nicht
reichen werden
das ist glück geht es durchs raster
fällt es ist leider so dass haben aber
von angst oder bis wird die show betonen
wir sie nicht in eine zentralistische
system sondern in der föderalistischen a
und b sind die verschiedene maßnahmen
übergriffe sind sind kultur maßnahmen
position der maßnahme aber sie nahm
ausnahme von anderen ebene
die sind durch die bundes ins
schweizerische sozialversicherungssystem
und das kommen mit halb stehend oder
aufheben
um sich politisch gehör zu verschaffen
ist christoph thoma mit senat teil einer
task force die ans parlament appelliert
hat
die große befürchtung gehabt dass man
sein wird 80 ankauf dieser lage in der
tat besteht die gefahr dass sich viele
nicht über wasser halten können nimmt
der bund das in kauf
diese beziehung so viel kultur um
provozieren und einem entwurf geschafft
haben dass die maßnahmen mit bis 121 auf
schienen ebene nötig sie werde um genau
zu verhindern was sie sagen dass sowohl
strukturell wie auch individuell das
fruchtbare wort der flurbereinigung
realität wird veronika sparrenburg
konnte weiter arbeiten dank vorbezug und
der förderung von pro helvetia die
kulturstiftung hat in der krise eine
ausschreibung lanciert schloss distance
hier hat spielen burg ihr projekt muss
falls ein gerecht der sound von städten
während des lockouts lässt sich online
kunden dass sich spiegelburg nur mit
kurzfristigen fördergeldern und private
unterstützung ihre existenz sichern
konnte zeigt wie fragil das system ist
sie sind sich die empfehle den die krise
hat die lupe auf die prekären
bedingungen des systems gelegt die
diskussion ist angestoßen
die kulturschaffenden brauchen eine
bessere soziale sicherung damit sie
künftig mehr kunst machen können
statt über lebenskunst
[Musik]
ja die schöne natur wie etwa hier
oberhalb des princess das weiß auch
laura loosli zu schätzen
sie ist ebenfalls aus dem berner
oberland und ist eine von mehreren
20-jährigen die wir ihnen in einer web
serie vorstellen
unter dem titel wir 2000 zeigen wir
wofür junge menschen heute brennen und
bei laura loosli ist dass ihr beruf aus
preisgekrönte junge köchin und eben das
landleben mit vor als bessere von land
aus ihrer stadt wo wir einfach mehr
bezug zur natur vom wiener kollege
zimmermann sehr versteckt muss im grund
wird für luft aber die menschen sagen es
ist einfach übergangen und dass sie das
später schaue mir die zähne zusammen 88
[Musik]
im wald gibt sehr viele sachen machen
verwandelt für druck ich finde das ist
sehr schön ist wenn natur als gericht
wie bei zucker wird und so vertrauen
schenkt ich hoffe extrem gern kreativ
haus sie mir ist einfach eine frechheit
das kiju und machen wieder druck ist
neues leben
mir ist vor allem wichtig stadt ist das
war nie machen dass mir das freude macht
das so gemacht
[Musik]
ich finde es wichtig dass man weiß wo
das produkt rum und dass man jetzt mit
dem fleisch aber es hat das kurze aber
kann und dass man das ohne schlechtes
gewissen wenn er sich abgesetzt ohne aus
dass für sie das auch wieder zu dem
machen acht führer für das geld und
verzichtete auf eine persönliche
erklärung ist aus für junge familien
ration das machen für das was sie dafür
halten
das macht man ihm solo stuft erwachsene
das recht schnell
ich finde es eigentlich auch gut so wie
es ist wichtig dass er das macht er
gerne macht es ist überraschend wie man
vielleicht nicht so eindeutig gesagt
bist nicht mehr flüchten
angst macht eigentlich ein mensch der
verrichtet look der vatikan diese
generation unmöglich mache
das war unser ausflug aufs land da wo es
jetzt noch mehr menschen hin zieht seit
corona wo immer es sind sie diesen
sommer wir wünschen ihnen zauberhafte
wochen wir gehen jetzt in die
sommerpause und melden uns mitte august
wieder zurück dann nehmen wir sie mit in
die wilde natur in sophiental jetzt
gleich folgt lovely louis von bettina
oberli einen lovely sammer
[Musik]
haltlos
hätte
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos